we also have new information this
morning about an ongoing investigation
into president biden's son hunter
federal officials are looking at his
foreign business dealings including his
ties to a chinese energy company
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge is in washington
she's been following this for us
catherine good morning
good morning tony the investigation
began as in tax inquiry years ago and
has expanded into a federal probe
involving the fbi and irs a source
familiar with the investigation now
tells cbs news two men who worked with
hunter biden when his father was vice
president were called to the grand jury
last fall
multiple sources tell cbs news that the
federal investigation into hunter
biden's business practices is broader
than previously known the probe is
exploring whether the younger biden and
his associates violated tax money
laundering and foreign lobbying laws
records reviewed by cbs news and
documents released by republicans in
congress indicate multiple financial
transactions involving an energy company
called cefc republicans accuse the
business of being an arm of the chinese
government in 2017 the year joe biden
left the vice presidency a 1 million
retainer was signed with the chinese
energy company for hunter biden services
as a lawyer his client a cefc official
patrick co was later convicted on
international bribery and money
laundering charges for unrelated work in
africa here you have
hunter biden this week on the senate
floor republican chuck grassley
presented financial records that he said
showed six-figure payments from the
chinese energy company to hunter biden's
firm this is 100 000
from what is effectively
an arm of the communist chinese
government
direct
to hunter biden
allegations about hunter biden's foreign
business dealings reached a fever pitch
during the 2020 campaign where's hunter
and on tuesday former president trump
pushed an unproven claim about hunter
biden's business dealings in russia
calling on vladimir putin to release any
damaging information i would think
putin would know the answer to that i
think he should release it this was the
response from the white house what kind
of american let alone an ex-president
thinks that this
is the right time to enter into a scheme
with vladimir putin an attorney for
hunter biden did not respond to cbs news
regarding his business dealings last
year he told correspondent anthony mason
on cbs this morning that the president
did not financially benefit have you
ever given your father money from any of
your business ventures no nothing
nothing directly or indirectly directly
or indirectly
the white house declined to comment on
the record and referred reporters to an
earlier statement that president biden
has never considered being in business
with his family or any business overseas
gail
all right catherine thank you very much
a lot of questions there